Joe Biden says that he would not
legalize cannabis because it is a
supposed gateway drug so this is a very
good opportunity to dispel what is a
very tired and misunderstood talking
point and it's another confirmation not
that we needed one that Joe Biden's not
progressive period Joe Biden still has
some of the tired centrist ideas of many
decades pass so let's take a look at the
video from Joe Biden's rally in Las
Vegas Nevada over the weekend and then I
mean there's just so much to say about
this hello my name is Ricky I have to
question show my first question is has
your stance on recreational marijuana
changed and my second question is do you
mind signing a poster for me in the
moment I think look I think States
should be able to make a judgement to
legalize marijuana
I agree I think that's okay but let me
tell you the truth of the matter is we
there's not nearly been enough evidence
that has been acquired as the whether or
not it is a gateway drug it's it's a
debate and I want a lot more before I
legalize it nationally I want to make
sure we know a lot more about the
science behind it it is really important
to break this down into pieces and go
through it as I like to do step by step
because there's a lot of wrong
information here but we also don't want
to go further than the science tells us
we just want to be clear about what does
the science say and how do these things
work the concept of a gateway drug the
concept described by the idea of a
gateway drug is a real thing okay the
idea is you have a drug it's either in
and of itself not addictive or less
addictive but it leads to the use of
more addicting or deliberate
debilitating drugs that one may not as
readily get into directly were it not
through the Gateway or the door that is
opened by some other substance or drugs
so I'll give you an example prescription
opiate painkillers
have been proven to function as a
potentially dangerous gateway to street
heroin that's true that's a huge problem
you get a prescription for after some
medical procedure or an accident from a
doctor you become addicted you start
buying the same pills on the street you
realize heroin is cheaper so you switch
to the heroin the prescription opiates
for so many people
devastatingly have been a gateway to
street heroin that's a real problem
cannabis has not been shown to be a
gateway drug and there's actually a ton
of science about it you can go to Google
Scholar and you can read lots of studies
about it and the general findings after
I reviewed several dozen studies about
this are that there actually is a
correlation between very heavy cannabis
use and the use of harder drugs but the
problem is that that's deceptive and
that's as far as many people go there
are many people who will say well look
studies have shown that really heavy
cannabis users are more likely to also
be users or abusers of heavier drugs
there must be some causal relationship
this is a very different issue
altogether and we shouldn't conflate
what's going on a heavy cannabis user
could be more likely to get into harder
drugs regardless of their cannabis use
and regardless of the legality of
cannabis what I mean by that is if you
are the type of person who either for
biological reasons or circumstantial
family environmental reasons are more
likely to end up using heroin or cocaine
and crystal meth or whatever you are
also more likely to do that regardless
of whether cannabis is legal I hope I'm
being clear and what I'm saying here now
there is one way in which marijuana or
cannabis can be a gateway drug and it's
actually something that suggests we
should be legalizing it being around
drug-related violence being around drug
related guns and criminality and drug
dealing and that is happening in an
illicit way is going to put you in
situations where there are likely going
to be users of
heavier drugs around you you could get
sucked into it or into violence or
criminality simply by being around the
scene but that's actually an argument
for the legalization of cannabis to get
people who choose to use it away from
situations and circumstances where there
are heavier drugs or there are guns or
there is violence that is the way in
which cannabis being illegal can serve
as a gateway not just to using hard
drugs but also to getting people into
situations of criminality and violence
that are generated by cannabis being
illegal so back to Joe Biden it's no
surprise that this is what he's saying
he's being upfront and I disagree with
his position so the one thing I'm not a
Biden guy but this is yet more evidence
that Biden's not progressive the one
thing I appreciate that Joe Biden is
doing this election cycle and I've said
this before and some people get mad for
me pointing this out but it's true Joe
Biden doesn't seem to be pretending to
be a progressive in other words he makes
very clear on the stage he's not into
this medicare-for-all thing that other
people are talking about he makes it
very clear when he's asked I think
cannabis is a gateway drug and I
wouldn't legalize it
I disagree vehemently or as I like to
say vehemently even though I don't even
know where I heard it I just find it
funny I disagree vehemently with Joe
Biden on these positions but he's not
playing coy the way some other
candidates have been doing and it makes
it really clear that Biden's not the guy
for me I don't have to dig too deep to
figure that out so he's not the person I
want as the progressive as the
Democratic nominee rather he's not the
person I want as president but he's
being upfront with us he's completely
wrong but he is being upfront with us
here